à l'étranger encore imaginer un chef de
gouvernement qui s'absentent deux
semaines pour profiter d'un congé
paternité
eh bien c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer en grande-bretagne
le tout nouveau premier ministre david
cameron vient d'avoir son quatrième
enfant
il a voulu donner l'exemple sur place à
londres jacques cardoze stéphane
guillemot florence rose endellion et
papa cameron
la série de photos publiées ces
dernières heures était certes attendue
mais pas si vite car la petite fille
prématurée de quelques semaines est venu
bousculer l'emploi du temps de son papa
premier ministre c'est vraiment génial
on était en plein milieu des vacances on
pensait que l'enfant arriverait juste
après et finalement tout est arrivé très
vite
du coup david et samantha resteront en
cornouailles
il n'est pas question de politique dans
l'immédiat ça tombe bien les anglais
encore sur la plage préfèrent admirer la
photo du nouveau né similienne david
cameron doit faire sa rentrée politique
la semaine prochaine mais il entend
pleinement profité de son congé
paternité pour une durée inconnue
il en a informé son vice premier
ministre avant le week-end je suis très
heureux pour dévider samantha comme tout
le monde ils sont sans doute soulagé que
tout se soit bien passée et le bébé va
bien et j'espère que toute la famille va
pouvoir profiter de ce moment de joie
c'est la deuxième fois qu'un premier
ministre en exercice assume une
paternité en délaissant sa fonction le
temps d'un instant
tony blair avec son fils leo en 2000 n'a
pas pu en profiter pour lui même mais il
a mis en place le congé de paternité
pour les britanniques
trois ans plus tard un premier ministre
qui ne s'empresse pas de faire sa
rentrée politique voilà qui n'est pas
commun mais si david cameron a fait ce
choix c'est aussi parce qu'il sait que
ce moment heureux pour les britanniques
précède un autre moment plus douloureux
avec la mise en place de son plan
d'austérité
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler